In our waking hours, for much of our lives,
we are granted an unwarranted luxury: a sense
that we are immortal. Our organs function
normally, our joints give us no pains, we
are focused on the next few financial quarters
in the business. Dropping dead is the last
thing on our minds.
But this is not the case in the early hours.
Suddenly, there’s an odd gnawing twinge
in the stomach. It isn’t anything major,
and it might pass by tomorrow. But this might
also be the start of a tumour that will fell
us by the new year. Also, our chest feels
a bit tight. When we breathe, there can sometimes
be a sense of strain. There was an incident
a little while back at the airport, running
for the distant gate. Could it have been a
heart attack, a quiet one that passes largely
undetected but tears fatefully at a valve?
What about the slightly odd mole on one’s
back? Has it always been there or is it new,
spreading aggressively and malignantly? Why
can’t we remember the name of that really
nice colleague we worked with a few years
back? Is reason beginning to crumble? This
would be just the moment for a stroke which
will leave us half-paralysed; paramedics will
urgently wheel us along the A&E corridors
on a trolley bed. We’ll need to have our
bottom wiped by a nurse and be fed with a
tube coming out of our nose.
The sheer implausibility of being, and remaining
alive, grows overwhelming. How is it possible
that one can keep living, given everything
that might go wrong? It isn’t hypochondria
any more, that macabre almost fun state of
mind you can adopt as an adolescent, this
is a realistic assessment of the risks. It’s
the imagination correctly deployed.
This present ache or twinge might not announce
the end - but something will happen. The abstract
possibility of death turns, at night, into
a concrete, decisive fact. Perhaps we’ll
fall off a ladder trying to get a suitcase
out of a high-up cupboard and lie on the floor
for eight hours with a broken neck, blood
filling our lungs, before anyone finds our
discoloured limp body. Or maybe we’ll be
lucky and it will be a quick aneurysm on the
way back from a party celebrating a friend’s
birthday. Whatever it will be, it’s getting
closer. Others will be deeply distressed for
a while; a few people will be sad even years
later when they happen to think of us. But
they’ll cope. It won’t matter to anyone
the way it matters to us right now.
We’re appalled and awed by the deep strangeness
of being alive; it’s so fundamentally improbable
that the delicate web of our thoughts and
feelings is being sustained by a bunch of
pulpy, fragile organs. All our complicated
ideas and lovely movements of the soul depend
upon tiny mindless white blood corpuscles,
oxygen molecules and the rhythmic spasms of
the sinoatrial node. Why does the machine
keep going? Why aren’t we dead already?
The thoughts are horrific - and the full panic
may go on for half an hour or more. But as
we gradually grow used to the idea of being
obliterated and forgotten, the thought of
death sharpens our resolve: we have to do
the important things while we can. We need
to finish our work and dare to take up new
initiatives. We need to forgive more. We can
let a stupid comment pass; we can give up
on a feud, even though the other wronged us.
The visceral knowledge of our approaching
death renews our appreciation of existence.
It’s incredible to be able to hear a car
accelerating in the distance; it’s fascinating
to have feet; the pillow feels so nice on
our cheek; it will be lovely to look tomorrow
at a tree or to hear a song or bite into a
fig. We’re brought back to a proper sense
of the charm of things that ordinarily seem
too slight to notice but which are close to
why life is worth cherishing. The veil of
jaded familiarity is pulled back - at least
for a little while. A year starts to look
like a huge privilege to have. A day when
nothing much happens won’t be boring, it
will be magnificent opportunity to continue
to exist. Our perspective cards features tools
for a wiser, calmer perspective on life. They
help to restore calm and clarity even during
difficult times.